it seems like every job has at least one
co-worker that everybody in the office
avoids like the plague in Hollywood some
celebrities have earned a serious
reputation among their co-stars so much
so that the other actors don't want to
work with them
here are some celebs who flat-out
refused to work together the crime epic
the Irishman was a grand reunion of
Hollywood legends but Mickey Rourke
wasn't invited
according to page six he claimed on an
Italian TV show that he was in line for
a part in the film until one of the
stars stepped in and put the blocks on
it Rourke admitted that his problems
with Robert De Niro began in 1987 when
they appeared opposite one another in
the psychological horror movie angel
heart Rourke grew up idolizing De Niro
but his opinion changed after he
introduced himself on set he revealed
about five minutes later De Niro comes
over he said I think it's better if we
don't talk because of our characters in
the movie it's better if we don't say
hello talk or anything it hurt my
feelings a little bit because I looked
up to him
producers denied his claims in a
statement saying
Mickey Rourke was never asked to be in
the irishman nor was he ever even
thought of discussed or considered to be
in the movie back in the early 90s Mark
Wahlberg was better known as Marky Mark
the frontman of Marky Mark and the Funky
Bunch he wasn't taken very seriously in
Hollywood and when Leonardo DiCaprio
found out that Marky Mark was being
considered for a role in The Basketball
Diaries he apparently freaked out
Wahlberg told The Hollywood Reporter
Leonardo was like over my dead body
Marky Mark's not going to be in this
movie I was a bit of a to him at a
charity basketball game so he was like
this is not going to be in this movie
according to Wahlberg he and DiCaprio
both had quote a specific opinion about
each other prior to meeting but that all
went out the window as soon as they got
to work Wahlberg told extra once I
finally got to the point where I was
able to audition and read with him then
we just both kind of looked at each
other we were like wow we were literally
out that night and we became fast
friends
audiences fell hard for 2004's The
Notebook but according to the director
the drama sometimes continued after he
yelled cut co-stars Rachel McAdams and
Ryan Gosling apparently
in front of the entire crew nick
cassavetes told vh1 they were really not
getting along one day on set Brian came
to me and there's 150 people standing in
this big scene and he says would you
take her out of here and bring in
another actress to read off-camera with
me
I can't I can't do it with her I'm just
not getting anything from this now I
hate you useful producers called to
clear the air meaning after Gosselin
refused to shoot the big scene with
McAdams and it got off to a rocky start
the director explained they started
screaming and yelling at each other they
had it out I think Ryan respected her
for standing up for her character and
Rachel was happy to get that out in the
open
the rest of the film wasn't smooth
sailing but it was smoother sailing the
two actors ended up dating for a couple
of years after wrapping the notebook
rumors about a beef between Vin Diesel
and the fate of the Furious co-star
Dwayne Johnson turned out to be 100%
true it all kicked off when Johnson took
to social media to slam an anonymous
co-star during the last week of filming
sane in a since deleted Instagram
caption my female co-stars are always
amazing and I love them my male co-stars
however are a different story some
conduct themselves a stand-up men and
true professionals while others don't
the ones that don't are too chicken to
do anything about it anyway candy-asses
Johnson later confirmed that he was
indeed talking about Diesel who was
reportedly late to set on a regular
basis Johnson later told Rolling Stone
then and I had a few discussions
including an important face-to-face in
my trailer we have a fundamental
difference in philosophies on how we
approach moviemaking and collaborating I
wish him all the best and I harbor no
ill will there just because of the
clarity we have actually you can erase
that last part about no ill will we'll
just keep it with the clarity when the
film came out some suggested the Paris
scenes were shot to hide the fact that
they weren't even together on the set
Johnson confirmed saying that is correct
we were not in any scenes together and
will you ever film a scene with him
gotta play the pimp on that former NCIS
star pauley perrette has revealed that
she'll never return to the CBS
procedural because she's scared a former
colleague Mark Harmon she admitted on
Twitter I am terrified of Harmon and him
attacking me I have nightmares about it
Barret didn't go into specifics about
why she was so scared of Harmon claiming
that there was a quote very powerful
publicity machine keeping her quiet
she did however seem to confirm that she
was subjected to violence during her
time on the show tweeting I've been
supporting anti-bullying programs
forever but now I know because it was me
if it's school or work that you're
required to go to it's horrifying
I left multiple physical assaults I
really get it now
according to Vanity Fair the two actors
started shooting on different days to
avoid contact with one another before
Pret's departure check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite celebs
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]